♪ ♪
>> Tucker: JERRY BROWN SAYS
THERE WAS A REPUBLICAN WAR IN
CALIFORNIA TODAY.
INCLUDING ABOUT 50 REPUBLICANS
PLUS ALMOST EVERY DEMOCRAT IN
THE HOUSE THEY CAN FORCE THE
HOUSE TO VOTE ON IMMIGRATION
PROPOSALS IS A GOOD IDEA?
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> THINGS WERE HAVING ME.
THERE ARE SO MANY THINGS GOING
ON IN CALIFORNIA.
IT'S OUR BIGGEST ESTATE, SO I
THINK IT'S WORTH WATCHING.
WHY WOULD THE CONCERN OF FOREIGN
CITIZENS, CITIZENS FROM OTHER
COUNTRIES TAKE PLACE OF
CALIFORNIA?
>> IT'S A NATIONAL ISSUE.
THE HOUSE, THE SENATE AND THE
PRESIDENCY, WE ELECTED TO LEAD.
OUR BORDER IS NOT SECURE.
WE HAVE MILLIONS OF IMMIGRANTS
WHO COME HERE EVERY YEAR AT
ANOTHER HALF A MILLION THAT COME
ACROSS OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
WE'VE GOT TO HAVE A RESOLUTION,
WE HAVE TO HAVE -- I WOULD LIKE
TO SEE THE PRESIDENT GET WHAT HE
NEEDS.
WE HAVE UNACCOMPANIED MINORS
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY WITHOUT A
COURT DATE OR WITHOUT SHOWING